hello and welcome back to reality check
the show that delves into the
technological fiction of video games and
asks hey science where is this
incredible fun and probably very
expensive thing in real life
come on science get a move on today
anthems javelins try again there we go
there is no doubt the mech suits totally
exist today but they're a bit less of
this and more of this
[Music]
that's just a weird slow car
get it together science okay that sells
it we're gonna have to build one of
these ourselves however I'm gonna need
some help because the only material I
know how to build with is Lego and I
don't see how a Lego mech suit is
remotely balls my name is Jerry
Burroughs call myself the brick engineer
impressive credentials I stand corrected
however something tells me that that
suit would not last very long in a
firefight with the Dominion so to find
out what materials we should use to
build our very own combat ready javelin
I drafted in dr. Seuss Kundu brick
engineer I mean material scientists yes
that's the real thing
[Music]
the javelins in Anthem are made of metal
which is great because metals generally
are incredibly robust and they can be
shaped to create panels incredibly
easily the ideal kind of metal in this
situation would be something that is
strong but also low in density so
material like titanium would be ideal
for that however if we're thinking of
impact protection there could be other
ways that you can achieve this with a
cool bit of material science there's a
group of materials known as
non-newtonian materials which are
generally made of particles that flow
past one another in normal wearing
situations but on impacts the particles
lock together in doing so the material
briefly turns into a solid and the
impact dissipates across the material
rather than through it non-newtonian
materials huh now they sound pretty
sci-fi but they're actually already
incorporated into some modern-day body
armors for that solid to liquid
transformative property however there's
a very good chance that you have
encountered such a thing before as well
ever mixed cornstarch and water together
and then hit it with a hammer just me
wow that's a non-newtonian fluid you can
even fill a swimming pool with this
stuff and jump around on it because why
not
however non-newtonian are still pretty
bulky so we want to maintain the agility
of our javelins we're gonna need
something that is still super strong but
is also lighter anyoption system so
everyone's favorite wonder material
graphene could be the answer to this as
a two-dimensional material made just of
carbon atoms in a one atom thick layer
it's a little bit difficult to work with
graphene at the moment but it does have
properties that we want to make use of
low density high tensile strength if we
wanted to make a suit out of this I
reckon the best way forward would be to
combine the powers of some of these
different materials
perhaps embedding some of these graphene
layers within a non-newtonian foam so
that you can create a material that is
light but incredibly protective
okay so we have our composite material
it's light and it's tough but we are
only puny humans with limited muscles so
how on earth are we gonna be strong
enough to move inside these suits
well cutting-edge soldier tech like the
Talos and Prowler augmentation system
utilized XO frames to give the operator
the ability to go further and even lift
more so is building something like this
into our javelin the answer an EXO frame
is certainly one way that we could give
the wearer of the javelin a bit more
strength and stamina however there are
some limitations these are incredibly
bulky and they're very power intensive
so we could use some quirkier science to
get around this there's an incredible
area of research that's looking into
artificial muscles regular muscles work
by it being made of lots and lots of
fibers better able to shorten and then
lengthen thus creating movement in
artificial muscle you can create this
effect in a couple of different ways the
first way is to take a carbon nanotube
and twist it up until it's incredibly
tight this twist wants to stay very
short and when it's pulled apart it
wants to then pull back into place so
that can induce some movement another
way that you can achieve this is again
by using these carbon nanotubes but by
filling them with paraffin the carbon
nanotubes are made of a certain number
of carbon atoms and when they're heated
by increasing the temperature or by
inducing a very small electric current
the paraffin inside these carbon
nanotubes expands as it expands the tube
moves outwards but because it's made of
a certain amount of material it has to
therefore shorten to accommodate this
expansion of the paraffin inside by
using any one of these types of
technology you can create panels around
the wearer within a suit that can
enhance their performance
much like its long and pointy namesake a
javelin is at its best when zooming
through the air that's right these mech
suits can fly and we might be closer to
this reality than you think
enter British engineer Richard browning
and his team at gravity industries cool
huh
this jet suit can reach speeds of up to
32 miles per hour and heights of 12,000
feet less impressive though is it's
flight time of 5 to 10 minutes which is
to impart to its 27 kilograms of weight
and that's without fuel let's just say
missions from fort Tarsus would barely
get started if that's all the flight
time we had to play with Suze what's
your take on this one on a planet like
Earth
we're hurtling towards the ground at
9.81 meters per second in order to
escape that we need to generate a lot of
thrust in order to do that and make it
as efficient as possible we need to be
as light as possible so we can get
around that problem by incorporating
these light materials into the suits
such as the graphemes and the phones
that we've already talked about however
one more thing we need to consider is
the amount of heat being generated when
we create this crust we need to make
sure that this excess heat doesn't reach
vital components in the suit so we need
a material that doesn't just conduct
heat but can direct it away from these
components a perfect material would be
something like graphite it's made of
lots and lots of these graphene sheets
lay it up one on top of the other to
create a highly ordered structure so not
only can it get rid of that heat it can
move it on well away from places where
it might cause a problem
aha so that's why I plummet to the
ground whenever I allow my javelin to
overheat good to know clearly needs more
graphics so tell me what's your take on
creating a real-life javelin do you
think that with the right mix of
advanced enough materials we will
eventually get there or is this one
technology to the fundamental laws of
physics might deny us
let me know in the comments down below
or by tweeting to me directly at cam for
Azeroth my huge thanks to dr. Seuss can
do for her expertise on this one and
also thanks to you for watching
[Music]